I'm experiencing sharp stabbing pains through my body, chest pains that go into my arms.
I am very sensitive to being touched.
Everything hurts.
What can I do?
General practitioner prescribed a muscle relaxer, steroid, oxycautin, none of these have
helped.
I take tumoric twice a day, but nothing seems to stop the pain.
Sharp stabbing pains throughout your body, chest pain that goes into your arms, very sensitive
to be touched.
You always have to ask the question, where is that coming from?
Why is that?
That's the question you want to ask.
If you have not done a cheek swab asking about this specifically, please do a cheek swab asking
about this specifically, because I would, you know, that would help get to the bottom
of that.
Let me see.
Who was it that asked these questions here?
No, this person has not done a cheek swab real recently.
We should do another one to get to the bottom of that.
So what could be causing this, could, could cancer be causing this sharp stabbing pains
through the body?
Well, it depends on where the cancer is, versus brain cancer, absolutely.
So if you have, stabbing pains throughout your whole body, you have to think of it has
to be what's called an upper motor neuron lesion, lesion just means it injury, okay?
So there's something going on with an upper motor neuron, what's that mean?
That means the brain and the spinal cord.
So if you have metastasis to the spine, there could be pressure on the spinal cord, and
then you could have pains anywhere from that point down.
So if I have, let's say metastasis to my T12, my 12 thoracic vertebrae, and it's putting
pressure on my spinal cord, I wouldn't get stabbing pains in my arms.
I'd get stabbing, I could get pains if it's affecting what are called aferent fibers
that are coming back to the brain if that's what the pressure on the, the cancer in the
spinal cord is pushing on.
I could have symptoms that are, that are subjective, meaning pain, numbness, tingling, hot cold
sensations, things like that, but it'd be south of that lesion, it'd be below that lesion.
So it could be, it's T12, it could be my stomach, it could be in my legs, et cetera, but
I wouldn't be having shoulder pain, I wouldn't be having arm pain.
So upper motor neuron lesions in the spinal cord and in the brain.
So if I'm having it literally all over my body, you got to start thinking of where else could
I, you know, what else could be putting pressure on this nerve?
Well, a person could have no, no sign of cancer, no history of cancer and they could have
these type of symptoms.
Well, then you start going to where, what's causing inflammation in the brain?
So it doesn't just space out to find lesion like a cancer, it could be something that's
causing inflammation in the brain.
So perfect example is post-concussive central person had a concussion, multiple concussions
years ago and now they're experiencing these weird pain symptoms all over their brain,
body.
So the example would be Lyme disease that affected the brain, another example would be effects
of a vaccination, so were you vaccinated?
These adjuvoks and vaccinations, randomly cross the blood brain, bury cause inflammation
of the brain, cause damage microglial cells in the brain, wrapped up inflammation that you
could experience, these weird symptoms throughout your whole body.
What will help these things, well, Tumeric is a good choice here, this is very good,
Tumeric, curcumin, but twice daily taking Tumeric, I mean, you want to decrease inflammation
that's going on in upper motor, in the spinal cord or in the brain, you have to take fairly
high doses, we're talking at least four grams of this a day.
Many people will say eight grams and you have to add other flavonoids to this, we've spoken
a lot about flavonoids, I won't type them out, Resveratrol, Green Tea Extract, EGC, Corsatin,
White Willow Bark, Boswellia, these are the flavonoids that are been proven to decrease inflammation
of the brain in the spinal cord, so but you have to take high doses of it and you have
to spread it throughout the day because all these flavonoids have a very short half-life
in your body, we need to dissipate and are gone quite quickly, so if you have like Tumeroclear
or you have curcuclear, you need to be taken like maybe one an hour to get ahead of this
and knock this down, a matter of fact, if a muscle relaxer did it help and if a steroid
did it help and if oxycut did it help, that even points more towards brain inflammation
and microglial primate because all the studies that were funded through billions of dollars
into the post-coccus of study that have been done with inflammation of the brain and microglial
primate brain damage, a matter of fact I have several videos on this that you can watch
in the I know they're in the courses and I know they're in blog posts, they found that
these drugs don't really work very well, what worked is the flavonoids, so high dose flavonoids.